digamos que se les acerca a alguien en
la calle y les da esta expresión x
cuadrada más 7 x + 10 / x + 2 y les dice
a ver si puedes simplificarlo pausa en
el vídeo y traten de hacerlo una forma
de pensar en esto es a que es igual x
cuadrada más 7 x + 10 dividido entre x +
aquí hay dos formas de resolverlo una
forma es tratar de factorizar el
numerador y ver si tiene algún factor
que sea común con el denominador vamos a
hacerlo esto ya lo hemos hecho muchas
veces y si esto es nuevo para ustedes
los invito a que revisen la
factorización de polinomios en otros
vídeos de khan academy pero que par de
números al sumarlos dan 7 y al
multiplicarlos dan 10 pues son 2 y 5
podemos reescribir el numerador como x +
2 x x 5 y en el denominador seguimos
teniendo x + 2 y podemos ver claramente
que hay un factor común siempre que x no
sea igual a menos
porque si x es igual a menos 2 toda esta
expresión se vuelve indeterminada por
tener cero en el denominador así que
mientras x no sea igual a menos 2
podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador entre x más 2 nuevamente la
razón por la que puse esta restricción
es porque no podemos dividir el
numerador y el denominador entre 0 así
que para cualquier otro valor de x este
x + 2 será diferente de 0 y podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre él por lo que se cancelan y nos
queda x 5 otra forma de pensar en esto
es que podemos ver la expresión original
como x + 5 para cualquier x diferente de
menos 2 ahora la otra forma de resolver
esto es mediante la división larga
algebraica que es bastante similar a la
división larga con la que están
familiarizados desde me parece el cuarto
grado lo que hacemos es tomar x + 2 y lo
usamos para dividir x cuadrada +
7 x + 10 y en esta técnica nos fijamos
en el término de grado mayor tenemos x
acá y x al cuadrado acá y nos
preguntamos cuántas veces cabe x en x
cuadrada pues cabe x veces ahora
escribimos esto en esta columna porque x
es x a la primera potencia y podemos ver
esto como la columna del primer grado
que es análogo a los valores posicional
es de los que hemos hablado cuando
aprendimos a reagrupar y sobre los
valores posicionales pero aquí podemos
verlos como valores de grados o algo
parecido y ahora tomamos la equis y la
multiplicamos por toda esta expresión x
por 2 es 2x que ponemos en la columna
del primer grado x por x es x cuadrada y
ahora lo que queremos hacer es restar lo
que está en amarillo de lo que
originalmente tenemos en azul por lo que
lo hacemos así nos queda 7 x menos 2x es
igual a 5x y x cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada es cero y luego bajamos el más
nos fijamos en el término de grado mayor
x cabe en 5 x 5 veces es de grado 0 o
una constante por lo que lo escribimos
en la columna de las constantes 5 por 2
es 10 5 por x es 5x y ahora restamos
estos de lo que tenemos arriba y noten
que no nos queda residuo lo que es
interesante de la división larga
algebraica que probablemente hayan visto
en algunos vídeos es que podemos tener
algún residuo esas son situaciones en
las que la técnica de factorización que
vimos no funciona en esta situación este
modelo sería el más fácil pero esta es
otra forma de pensar en ello podemos
decir mira x + 2 x x 5 es igual a todo
esto ahora si queremos reescribir esta
expresión como lo hicimos aquí y decir
que esta expresión es igual a x + 5
tenemos que restringir el dominio y
decir que se cumple para todas las x que
sean diferentes a menos 2 para que estas
sean expresiones completamente idénticas